Welcome back to human emotion. Um,
today we're going to talk about crying.
So crying is something that really
punctuates the human life course from our
start is helpless.
Infants through adulthood.
Tears seem to mark our most
important life moments, weddings,
births,
deaths.
This capacity to cry really appears
to be this fundamental part of being a
human.
And it's really an important signal of
some of our most salient life events.
Yet,
why do we cry?
Why do we have these sort of glands
that excrete water coming down our face?
What function does it serve and what
happens in our bodies when we cry?
Um, so today we're going to try to grapple
with some of these questions about an
experience that's familiar
to almost all of us,
which is a time we remember crying.
And as we can see here,
crying not only occurs in infants,
but occurs throughout the lifespan.
So we,
like I said,
we cry from birth all the way to death
and it appears to be part and parcel of
being human.
And crying appears at least
to be important in some way,
although mysterious for
our emotional wellbeing.
So we see crying also
widely spread in the media.
So we can see examples here
of, oh, President Obama, um,
who cried. You know, it says here,
cried while thanking the
campaign workers in Chicago.
We see crying also in the
media with Hillary Clinton. Um,
we see it pervasive everywhere in our
life, even in the political sphere.
We also see songs that have been devoted
exclusively to talk about crying.
So one of my favorite bands, the
cure has a song. Boys don't cry.
And this not only speaks about crying to
speaks about some of our beliefs about
who ought to cry and in what
context should they cry.
There's other popular songs such
as the crying game by Boy George.
And this is all to highlight that
crime is part of what makes us human.
And in many ways,
we wouldn't be who we are if we didn't
cry throughout our lifespan in public and
private spheres and even devoting songs,
it's exclusively to crying.
So with all this emphasis on crying,
being such an integral part of
our most salient life experiences,
why do we cry?
And what can we learn about human crying
that's going to help us in our own
life? So today we're going to try
to talk about crying. And again,
what I want you to first think about,
and I think what all captures
our attention is to think
about a personal time in
your own life that you
can remember crying.
So I want you to take a moment and
pause this video and go through this
exercise, your own personal crying
reflection exercise. So again,
when you're crying and
you've identified a moment,
I want you to write down what
elicited the crying sort of episode,
what was going on in
your body when you cried?
What were the features of the crags?
Sort of what did it sound like?
What did it look like?
How long did it last?
Did it have any possible social effects?
And how did you feel after
you had finished crying?
So pause the video, take a moment to
write this down. And once you're ready,
you can hit play again.
And we'll proceed with the lecture today.
So today we're going to be
talking about crying. You know,
do we have tiers to express our fears?
Are there tears of joy?
What do these tiers in our
life actually mean to us?
What do they symbolize and
what can we learn about crying?
So let's think about our roadmap here.
We'll start with underlying theories that
people believe to have been true about
crying.
Then we'll get to some really subtle,
a contextual factors that suggest that
what makes crying adaptive are good for
us is actually really dependent on the
context and an actually much more complex
rich mystery about crying then
we could have ever imagined.
We'll conclude them with our takeaway
questions and expert interview with a
renowned authority on human crying.
So let's first start with our own
lay theories about why do we cry?
What is the function and purpose
of crying in the first place?
I always like to start with some of
these quotes that suggests that crying is
good for us,
that it seems to be strongly beneficial.
So you can read here early writing
saying that it is a relief to weep.
Grief is satisfied and
carried off by tears.
So this kind of early lay opinion
suggests that crying must be strongly
beneficial in some way. It helps us
sort of wash away our grief and worries.
And here is,
we'll see,
we'll go through several common beliefs
about crying that have evolved since
then.
So in popular articles we see in the news,
in the media and books,
it all suggests to us that well,
crime must be healthy.
So there was an analysis done of 140
years of popular articles about crying.
And in these articles,
94% suggested that crying is beneficial,
but it must be good for us.
And in fact that when you try to
suppress or hold back your tears,
that that is actually
going to be deleterious,
that it's actually going to
hurt your body and your mind.
So this suggests that we should cry
as we feel it and that by crying we're
actually doing something healthy for us,
that it almost has this
cathartic function for us.
There's also been cross cultural studies
as you can see her that also suggests
that crimes Cathartic. So a survey
was done spanning 30 countries.
And these surveys found that when
you just ask people to report,
well how did you feel after you finished
crying that people by and large report
feeling better after crying.
So again,
we seem to have this belief
and some research suggesting
that crying is good for
us. There was also these
more psychodynamic theories.
So these are sort of originated by
Sigmund Freud who suggested that blocking
tears or is holding them back
actually causes psychological damage.
So in psychotherapy you would actually
want to encourage your clients or
patients who are feeling distressed,
feeling depressed, feeling anxious,
just to kind of let the tears out,
right?
To sort of cry openly in therapy sessions
because this was in some way going to
cleanse them of their worries and fears.
And then finally there's these biochemical
theories of crying that suggests,
well, there's actually a sense
in which tiers rid our body,
kind of expel out these
harmful toxins in our bodies.
So all of these common theories about
crying suggests uniformly it will of
course crying must be good for us.
And all we need to know is
that when we feel like crying,
we should just let the
tears pour out, right? Or,
or is there more to this story
than crying is simply good for us.
Here I want to ask the question
then is crying really healthy?
And here I want to sort of think of us
as almost a Sherlock Holmes where we want
to go in as scientists,
as students in a course on human emotion
and ask ourselves where exactly is the
evidence? Where's the scientific
proof that crying is healthy?
We want to go beyond just people's
beliefs about crying, go beyond, you know,
anecdotal evidence and popular articles
and set up a scientific study using the
same research methods we talked about
earlier in the course to really see where
the data leads us.
So I'm going to lead you on a beginning
of this Sherlock Holmes investigation
and actually suggest that maybe crying
isn't always healthy and in fact maybe
there's a nuance story to win.
It is healthy and when it
might actually not be healthy.
So this is going to lead us into some
rich and subtle contextual factors that
are going to determine for us when,
where and for whom crying
is actually healthy.
So example one crying is healthy
but it depends on the context.
So it depends first on how
you actually measure crying.
And what do I mean by this?
So I'm going back to some of the methods
that we spoke about earlier in the
course.
So here we find that when you do self
report surveys and you measure the
benefits of crying retrospectively,
so you ask people to self report how
they felt after they cried that indeed 60
to 70% of people report
crime crimes Cathartic.
They report feeling less tension, they
report feeling more relief. However,
if you do laboratory studies,
so bring people into the lab,
have them watch a film
that makes them feel sad,
that elicits tears or recall a memory,
their own personal
autobiographical memory.
And you measure their response
immediately after crying.
So one to two minutes later that
people actually report feeling worse.
So they report feeling sad and the report
feeling more physiologically aroused
or they actually show it in there in the
physiological measurements when they're
watching sad films.
So it actually seems to show very
different evidence if you use surveys,
which suggests it's beneficial
as opposed to loud studies,
which suggest it may not always
feel so good to cry. Okay,
here's another example,
whether or not crying is good for us
also depends on these social context.
And by social context what we're talking
about is whether you are around other
people or you're alone by yourself crying.
We can probably both remember examples
of each and the example that you thought
of at the beginning of the class. Was
it around others or was it by yourself?
So we find that when we're actually
around other people crying that crying.
What it does around other people is it's
signaling to others that you want to,
um,
you know,
seek some solace and you solicit
comfort from other people.
So when you're around people,
then the benefits of crying man actually
come from the social support of people
coming up to you,
embracing new,
trying to help you as opposed to maybe
the actual act of crying in and of
itself.
Because when we're alone and we cry,
there's no one there to provide comfort
for us. And so when we're crying alone,
we don't seem to reap these
positive health benefits. Okay.
Another example suggests that whether or
not crying is beneficial depends on the
person.
So it depends on their personality
as well as their gender.
So what do we find in
terms of these things?
So in terms of personality,
we find that people who score higher in
a personality trait called neuroticism.
So this is a trait that is often
thought to involve greater emotional
instability.
So sort of more volatile ups and downs
in their emotions that these people
actually report more frequent
crying episodes and that
of those crying episodes,
they don't seem to sort of
reap the benefits from them.
They actually report feeling
more distressed and more
aroused from crying. Um,
when we think of gender differences,
we find that adult women cry more
frequently and intensely than men.
So it seems that both personality and
gender characteristics have a profound
influence on the nature
and frequency of crying.
There's still a lot of
evidence that needs to however,
be discovered as to whether or not
crying is more or less beneficial.
For example, in men versus women.
We don't know that answer yet.
So there's a lot of, um, uh,
answered mysteries at this point
too about crying of a fourth
example is that crying really depends on
the emotional state of the person as to
whether or not it's going to be good
for them or bad for them, so to speak.
So let me flush out what I mean by this.
So what we see here is that people,
for example,
who have a history of depression
or who are feeling depressed,
that when they cry,
they actually experience less
improvement in their mood after crying.
So they don't seem to sort of
reap the cathartic benefits.
They don't necessarily feel better after
crying as opposed to people who don't
have a history of depression who
may read more of these benefits.
Okay.
If you also look at anxiety,
um,
research has found that anxious people
as well are less likely to feel better
after crying.
So people who have a history of depression
or anxiety appear not to reap the
benefits that many of us
associate with crying. So again,
it really depends on the emotional
makeup of the person as to whether or not
crying is actually helping them
or may even be hurting them.
Okay.
However,
and what this point suggests here is
that clearly more studies are needed only
until very recently on a lot of
the work done by John Rottenberg,
who's part of the experts in
emotion interview for this series,
we had really seen just a complete
lack or dearth of scientific data.
And so we need to do many more rigorous
studies on the nature of crying to
really unlock its mysteries and either
try to confirm more of this everyday
intuition that crying is good for us
or disconfirm it by saying it actually
isn't good for us.
You know,
always in every condition at
every time and for every person.
So for those of you interested in crying,
here's a call to you to become a scientist
and researcher of crying so we can
better understand this everyday
common experience that we've all had.
Yeah.
So now I'm going to move to our
takeaway questions for today.
The first question from today really just
asks you to remember what were some of
these early theories or
beliefs about crying.
And a lot of them are focusing on the
ways in which crying is thought to be
beneficial.
Second,
how does the measurement of
crying influenced findings
concerning whether or not
crying is actually beneficial for us?
Whether we use subjective reports, uh,
that are more retrospective or versus
more laboratory based assessments.
And finally, how do factors
such as gender, personality,
social contexts as well as
sort of emotional disposition
or makeup influence the
potential benefits of crying.
Okay.
And I'd like you also to go back to the
exercise and we had at the beginning of
class and to think about
what you learned today,
how does it change the way you think
about your own individual or episode of
crying?
Does it change the way you think about
what the possible effects were or what
was going on in your body
or what the context was? Um,
when you are crying that
may have determined whether
or not you found it healthy
or may be harmful.
Okay.
And with that,
we'll now turn to our expert interview
as part of our experts and emotion
interview series.
Yeah.
For our experts and emotion interview,
we have the honor speaking with
Doctor Jonathan Rottenberg, um,
a leading researcher in the area
of emotion and psychopathology.
Jonathan Rottenberg has pioneered
efforts to integrate the basic science of
emotion with the study of psychopathology.
He received his phd from Stanford
University and is currently an associate
professor of psychology at the University
of South Florida where he directs the
mood and emotion laboratory.
He's the lead editor of an n
of emotion and psychopathology,
bridging effect of and clinical science.
And he's authored over 30
scientific publications. His work,
not surprisingly focused on
depression as well as crying,
has received international media coverage,
including science news,
Scientific American, the
New York Times, ABC News,
and the BBC.
He also writes a blog.
I'm about depression for psychology today.
Um,
one fun fact about Jonathan Rottenberg
is that he decided in his early forties,
he was going to train for a marathon,
and by the time we'll speak with him,
he'll have already run
three during that time.
So I now turn to our experts and
emotion interview with Doctor Jonathan
Rottenberg, answering the question
of, is crying actually good for us?
Yeah.